i've spent 30 years
with the opportunity having uh not work
but having more fun every day
maximizing the platform of the dallas
cowboys somebody looks the other way i
said whoa whoa come on back over here
and look at the cowboys
and when it got a little dull i tried to
liven it up a little bit from time to
time
oh jerry jones livens it up all the time
and the dallas cowboys continue to be
one of the marquee franchises in all of
sports it really is amazing when you
think that for the most part over the
past quarter century the cowboys have
been slightly above average just
slightly if that and they still continue
to have a following unlike any other
team
every network wants cowboys games
everybody wants to talk about the
cowboys the ultimate polarizing team
imagine what it would be like if they
actually were contenders every year
chris they have not been to an nfc
championship since the last year they
won the super bowl 25 years ago but yet
the cowboys continue to be a team that
sucks a lot of oxygen out of the room
because everyone wants to know what's
going on with them they are number 12 on
the preseason power rankings look some
people think that's a little bit low but
it just fits with the recent formula for
the cowboys big talk big talent big
expectations and they don't deliver and
that's kind of where they fit right now
even though i'm optimistic that with
mike mccarthy there's the head coach
i i think they could be better what's
the best thing you think their new coach
brings to the table yeah well mccarthy i
think just toughness and like um what do
i want to say
you know game plan that you know uh
that goes together cohesiveness you know
you've heard me say this issue before
with the last regime there in dallas i
felt like the offense just went out and
went hey this is what we do we're going
to play offense and the defense went
this is what we do we're not going to
change anything you know i think
mccarthy is going to have game plans
that complement each other that was the
word i was looking for that will
ultimately lead to putting the team in
the best place to win the football game
so i think that the attention to detail
mccarthy the toughness you know and
being a coach that's won a super bowl
and been there and done that and of
course made the the green bay packers
very relevant for a long long time you
know i think that's what he's going to
bring to that uh the table there in
dallas more than anything
yeah i agree with you there and
sometimes you just need change for the
sake of change it was a long 10 years
and you know i think jerry jones took a
lot of pride maybe excessive pride in
discovering and grooming and believing
in jason garrett i remember after he
finished his first contract with the
team jerry jones was intent on keeping
him because basically he said hey we've
suffered through the growing pains for
jason garrett as a head coach now we get
to benefit from the fully finalized
product and the problem is it just never
got them to where they want to be
mccarthy has shown he can get to the top
of the mountain he's shown he can get
closer to the top of the mountain than
the cowboys have since 1995. what do you
think the biggest change is chris that
he needs to make
within that roster within that
organization within that mindset to
punch through to the next level that
they've been striving to get to for 25
years well i i think it'll be about you
know kind of what we just talked about
still like situational football
how to you know you know what we're
gonna do on a second and eight and
what's the theme of our team to it's
gonna get us to third and manageable or
taking shots or whatever it may be you
know to me he's gonna come up with
themes in which they want to play
and then go wait here's a strength of my
team let's you know hey kellen winslow
or kellen moore let's get together
and try to figure out more ways to
utilize these strengths
i think that's what's interesting you
know to me and again you know you hit on
it you know you said yeah 12 and some
people think it's a little low well it's
a top 10 roster in football it is i mean
there's no doubt about that you know you
look at the roster in totality and you
go where is there really a weakness you
know maybe you could point to corner
right now right opposite of cherdobia
woozay you know because they lost byron
jones but after that
damn i mean with the signing of everson
griffin that was the only area i looked
at to go oh do they have a guy that's a
proven commodity are we really just
gonna rely on aldon smith and randy
gregory and doris armstrong or a rookie
you know so now they get everything
griffin too
with a new scheme under mike nolan i
just think it's to be a totally new look
dallas cowboys let alone
they have one of the most i mean as we
sit here right now it's one of the most
dangerous offenses in football i mean
it's dangerous when you talk about those
three receivers you know and and and and
everything i heard michael irvin say
last week at golden state okay maybe i
don't want to go that far but i think
between that offensive line ezekiel
running the football and then you talk
about cooper gallup and cd lamb to go
along with a good young tight end and
blake jarwin you go holy cow you know
the cowboys they might play through
their offense a little bit more than
we've seen in years past yeah the
defense is good but i think they'll be
able to push the envelope on people with
their offensive scheme and talent to
where they're going to really be able to
put pressure on team that way too
yeah i agree with you there and cdlam so
far the returns have been spectacular uh
the things that he will be able to bring
to that offense and you know chris we
talked so much about ezekiel elliott and
he's been as stephen jones said last
year the straw that stirs the drink well
the real straw is the quarterback and
dak prescott for all the great things
he's done
the wins haven't been there we talked
yesterday about how a quarterback can
influence winning a patrick mahomes his
attitude the term that eric the enemy
used to describe his motivation yeah his
his his effort to hold himself and
others accountable what's the next level
for dak prescott to take that
performance which if anything has been
underrated and translated into more
success on the field winning the games
that count the most getting to the
playoffs and piling up the victories
when they get there well you know again
yeah there are some big games and big
moments where you'd like to see okay
yeah dak prescott get on my back i'll
carry you through these big moments and
everything like that hey yes certainly
but i mean i think we're being picky you
know when we say that you know this is
still a guy that's what never had a
losing season as a starting quarterback
and i really look at some of the issues
that he's had and the offensive side has
had is not really his issues i looked at
them as offensive issues you know even
again at the end of the year last year
you know we started to stall in the
philadelphia game that's where i'll
remember it went back to we're going to
line up in the same formation and never
have any motion and i don't really know
what the game plan is or what the game
you know the plan of attack is on the
offensive side of the ball you know
that it's not easy to play quarterback
that way just being all over the place i
mean do you think drew brees or tom
brady in new england all those years
just were like hey just call plays and
we'll figure it out no mcdaniel sean
payton they tell them the logic behind
the plays and how they're going to tie
things together because it makes sense
to do it this way during the week and i
don't know you know by what i see on
film i don't think he's had the benefit
of the doubt that way so i think that's
where it's going to be refreshing this
year for dak prescott and i would be
shocked if the play is not better uh i i
really i would be truly shocked just
because of the talent i think the guy's
a hard worker and is going to get better
it's such a basic concept that you know
if you come out in the same alignment
for every play
the defense is not going to be all that
confused about what you're ultimately
going to do now everything you do flows
from that same alignment so i guess the
defense doesn't know what's coming
because they line up the same way every
way but but once you start moving guys
around and doing all sorts of shifting
and motion and
that puts stress on the brains of the
defensive players
maybe it's something they've never seen
before they've studied the film now what
the hell are these guys doing and
there's all these distractions and and
uh and we don't know where to go and
where do we go here and who has this guy
and what you know and and it can
overwhelm a defense mentally so why it's
amazing they haven't done it
and i i sense that you firmly believe
that that's one of the big changes we're
going to see this show i do yeah i just
think mike mccarthy is going to be able
to evaluate his football team the right
way and realize oh wait we do this
really well you know we're really strong
at these positions and he's going to
come up with game plans they're going to
tie it all together and make sense you
know that that to me will be the big
deal and you know i love that kellen
moore that he kept him on staff too
because you've heard me complain mike
mccarthy yeah he's really good at kind
of figuring out the right way to attack
and do those things and have a cohesive
game plan but sometimes to me it's
lacked a little imagination too as
you've heard me say in years past where
i want to go yeah i understand green
bay's approach but this is like the
first you know this is this is a play
from the second day of training camp and
they're running it too much and i don't
care if the approach is right or not
that's going to be the defense is going
to catch on to that you know i think
kellen moore is going to add more to
that offense and i heard mike mccarthy
in his press conference say he went back
to the drawing board to look at more
stuff offensively to implement in his
scheme and those things so yeah that's
where i'm excited about it and you know
when you look at it there on paper with
the dallas cowboys i mean of course on
paper they're the best team in the nfc
east
but i don't know can they get out their
own way can they put it all together
here can they beat the philadelphia
eagles so i look at the team they're
going to have to compete with in that
division to say we're the king of of the
nfcs i don't know
yeah it seems it seems like every year
the cowboys are the best team on paper
in the nfc east if not in the nfc but
something happens along the way what
happened last year was the ezekiel
elliott holdout and when he returned he
wasn't quite the same guy presumably
because he missed all that time in
training camp he didn't have the same
burst chris as you pointed out he'd get
out into the open field and he wouldn't
take it the distance or continue he'd
get caught up with from behind right and
brought down
ezekiel elliott salty about last year
about the criticism even though he had a
big season here he is talking about what
he's trying to prove in 2020
yeah i think i do have a lot to prove uh
you know i just have a high expectations
of myself and um
i mean it's not something you can go on
force you just gotta you know grind go
to work every day and uh
and let it happen
are they going to get themselves into a
we only have one football
problem
with
three receivers one of whom amari cooper
openly talking about all three of them
having more than a thousand yards
receiving this year ezekiel elliott is
going to want his opportunities to prove
himself is it going to be
an awkward balance between the running
game and the passing game when you have
one of the best running backs and now
you're going to have one of the best
passing attacks no i think they'll be
okay i i do i mean you know again is
somebody at the end of the year maybe
going to be a little disappointed at the
receiver position and go man i wish i
could have had a few more receptions
stuff like that
yeah but again
these are
you know first class problems here you
know and you look at any great offense
they usually have and not including the
quarterback three
weapons on the offensive side of the
ball that
make a defense go oh man i mean great
offenses usually have that to where it's
like oh i don't know what to do here
wait it's michael thomas it's alvin
kamara and it's jared cook who do i
cover you know you know you know so you
go through great offenses a lot of the
times they had that you know i go back
to new england in the days with
gronkowski and wes welker and edelman
and you're just like whoa okay which one
do we double what do we do here no but
it's going to be on kellen moore and
mike mccarthy to make sure that they
make these receivers especially feel
included you know you can find cheap
ways to get them included too whether
that's you know those speed sweeps
reverses screens to the receivers those
are cheap ways to run the football
without really running the football and
putting the wear and tear on ezekiel
elliott you know those things will make
guys feel included even though the
receptions and things won't go their way
either and then of course just success
of your offense is going to quiet things
down in a hurry too when guys start to
see wow we're we're wide open we're
getting catches we're moving the ball
this is fun it's just great to be a part
of that's what they got to strive to be
and then they'll have no issues
we mentioned the arrival of everson
griffin who will be the bookend to
demarcus lawrence in that pass rush but
gerald mccoy one of the interior
defensive linemen acquired this off
season along with ontario poe
gerald mccoy out for the year with a
ruptured quad that happened yesterday
another example of how lightning cannon
will strike at these various nfl
training camps how big of a deal is it
to not have gerald mccoy a guy who had
never played for the team before well i
mean it hurts because of that mike nolan
scheme it is going to be more multiple
it's going to be 3-4 and 4-3 everything
together you know the dallas the the one
thing or the one reason they can survive
it is they just have an unbelievable
amount of d tackles and defensive ends
on their roster to begin with let alone
a third rounder in oklahoma out of
oklahoma and neville gallimore who i
thought was just phenomenal like a top
40 pick type talent i thought coming out
in the draft so i don't think this is a
killer to them you know when you look at
antoine woods still there tristan hill
still there you know neville gallimore
the the aldon smiths you know tyrone
crawford he should be back in the swing
of things there i think they can survive
it without gerald mccoy it's going to
hurt it stinks those are really their
issues you know if you look at the
everything you go interior d-line and
then they got to figure out interior
o-line right the center-guard
combination of joe looney conor mcgovern
and connor williams who's going to be
the starters there how do they get the
best five on the field but to me those
are the pressing issues more than
anything that interior d-line interior o
line to get figured out for a great
roster
all right best case worst case for the
2020 cowboys chris
best case
i mean number one they're they're to me
they're capable of being the number one
team and being 13 and three in the nfc i
i i have no doubt about i think mike
mccarthy and the new coaching staff are
going to be worth at least one or two
wins just with the new energy and the
new focus in the building so i say
that's the best case 13-3 14 and two
yeah i think they're capable of doing
that i mean it wasn't that long ago they
did it so i look at that worst case
like like we saw last year i don't think
it could be much worse than that nine
and seven just miss out eight and eight
just miss out something like that
yeah best case for me is the one seed
and maybe a postseason run that includes
oh i don't know a date with aaron
rodgers in the green bay packers
that would be amazing for rogers and
mike mccarthy and and an old school
cowboys 49ers nfc championship oh yeah i
mean it looks like the 49ers are headed
there anyway so they may as well play
the cowboys there if the cowboys can
make it back for the first time since
the days when it was cowboys 49ers every
damn year in the nfc championship game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports